don't value somebody telling me what to
teach and how to teach my child child
about how to get along with other people
if my child doesn't do that well that's
on me
the overhaul of the proposed social
study standards
involves incorporating an additional
aspects to the educational opportunities
one of them is
incorporating diversity and they talk
about integrating race into the
discussion
of kids from kindergarten all the way
through
high school the goal is to
[Music]
provide
broader representation
of
a variety
of
of what it means for say american
history in particular or new mexico
history so making sure that all groups
of people are represented in a more
balanced and equitable way we are living
the nightmare as we speak i send my
child to school to be taught
math
reading
writing not another r which is race i'm
the one who has the credentials to teach
my children how to treat other people
when i started to understand what it was
it frightened me because i have two
children of color
and i've always taught them that this is
america
and whether you fail or succeed has
nothing to do with the color of your
skin but everything to do with how hard
you're willing to work
and this is antithesis the antithesis of
that in order to be able for people for
that student to grow into a citizen that
can stay engaged with people who have a
variety of opinions which i feel like is
kind of what we see
disintegrating sometimes in our country
they actually need to be
have the
vocabulary and the exposure to a range
of ideas so that they can actually have
an intelligent and thoughtful and
respectful conversation
educating children
that young about race and culture is
vital
to changing
our outlook on race and culture in this
society i think it can be helpful to
learn just about anything but when it
becomes
pushed one side or the other and not
just straight facts then it becomes an
issue and it shouldn't be done they're
putting the wrong ideas in these kids
heads you know like one group is
privileged the other group's not very
privileged we've got to be we've got to
live with each other this has got to
stop and and
it's got to stop i think there is these
people that are teaching this stuff are
teaching kids how to be racist really so
you know they really ought to you know i
don't even think that's
part of the should be part of the
curriculum i mean reading writing and
arithmetic should be what they're
teaching not this kind of stuff we're
51st in education in this state now that
they count dc and they go and lay out
social studies standards that are not
designed to fight our literacy issues
not designed to fight our math issues or
our writing issues they're designed to
divide kids and it makes no sense i
don't think that there's anything wrong
with teaching the good the bad and the
ugly
uh
of history our children need to learn
that but what we should not do is obsess
upon the differences that all of our
children have
um because all that does is create
division and animosity in the end when
we have a 30 percent literacy rate
uh and a 20 mass proficiency rate within
the albuquerque public school district
we are not educating our children and we
need to be focusing on that first and
then we can move on to other issues i
would really shy away from a false
dichotomy that says trying to do well in
this
area of education is necessarily at the
expense
on the contrary i feel like
all of the
areas of education
actually intersect and help support each
other
you know they're teaching our children
what to think not how to think and
that's the worst thing that can happen i
think when they start teaching what they
want about diversity in school it
becomes indoctrination and that's what's
happening
they're being taught something that
isn't true
starting from kindergarten
you know they're so vulnerable they're
so innocent
and this is what they're going to learn
is to judge people by their color little
brown kids will think they can't succeed
in this society and little white kids
are gonna feel guilty for some wrong
they never did
and that's the crux of it
the last thing any teacher wants is to
traumatize one of their kids they're
there because they want kids to flourish
they're clearly not there for the money
they're clearly not there for the fame
and so
i feel like
who better than people who have
literally devoted their entire
professional life to supporting the
flourishing of children
to be able to have both the expertise
and the sensitivity to bring those
conversations into the classroom these
types of topics if they're chosen to be
studied and investigated need to happen
at a college level
kindergartners
play with everybody
they're equal
what you're doing is you're identifying
everybody's differences in the same way
that you wouldn't hand a calculus
textbook to a kindergartener
but you would teach them their numbers
because otherwise when they get to high
school they're going to be really lost
you wouldn't hand a kindergartner
shakespeare but you will teach them how
to read because otherwise they're going
to be really overwhelmed and lost but
likewise you know you give
kids tools when they're very small to
build the foundation that enables them
to have the skills and the tools they
need to engage more difficult or nuanced
material
as they age